oh man I have waited too long to talk
about this I saw this movie like back in
November at the AFI Film Festival and I
have been holding this in for so long I
have wanted to talk about the end except
its film and the implications of it and
what it can mean for Shyamalan fans and
the future of what he may do with his
career I have just been sitting here
just like oh my gosh I can't we talked
about it so spoiler review of split if
you have not yet seen split I'm about to
talk in full detail about this movie I
already have a spoiler free review
that's going to be linked at the end of
this video so if you don't want to know
certain details now is your warning you
have been warned
let me fix something in my background so
this film takes place within the
universe of unbreakable I've only got to
talk about that as the film progressed
and as we learn more about his split
personalities and we got to see James
McAvoy doing all these crazy things the
film for me kind of pushed the limits of
believability when the doctor was like
you know people who have these types of
abilities can change their body
chemistry with their thoughts and I'm
like oh alright I mean I'll go with it
I've seen stranger things in movies but
as soon as he shows up shirtless with
his veins bulging out of his body I was
like oh is this the twist that he
actually is like a beast or something
like a man I really liked it up until
then and that's one of the things I want
to reiterate it I didn't just love this
movie because of the twist the twist
kind of filled in specific gaps of
issues that I had but I really enjoyed
the movie and then when the beast stuff
started happening I was like if you
remember back in my original review I
said that there's a moment of this film
where I was like I don't know if I'm on
board with this he just kind of has to
ride it out and wait and now that I know
that essentially what this is is an
origin story for a super villain I love
this movie
unbreakable is one of my favorite movies
of all time I love the
fact that it took a superhero story and
sold it in a more realistic grounded way
not just like Batman Begins in The Dark
Knight but in a very realistic way where
you feel as if you're not even really
watching a comic-book movie but you are
but it's more believable certain things
make more sense and that started in the
year 2001 the superhero comic book boom
hadn't happened yet so it's really cool
to see Shyamalan finally revisit those
roots and according to him at the
directors conversation at the end of the
screening at AFI he had actually written
this character that is portrayed by
James McAvoy back in 2000 or 99 whenever
he started writing a breakable this
character was part of his original three
movie arc of unbreakable at least that's
what Shyamalan said at AFI Fest but he
couldn't figure out how to include him
in the original film and now all these
years later we have an origin story for
a super villain in the unbreakable
universe and it just makes everything
else in the film work when you go back
and watch it a second time you see him
doing all these things like crawling on
the wall and crawling on the ceiling and
taking you know shots to the body and
bending those bars it's like that's his
ability he's extremely strong he's got a
crazy messed up mine he's
psychologically impaired he's a great
villain and if they decide to do more in
the unbreakable universe I am pumped to
see what they can do because as it pans
across that bar and when David Dunn
first Willis was revealed I'm telling
you the audience went insane at AFI I
was sitting next to Mark Ellis I grabbed
him by the shoulders and said holy shit
and shook him and we just like looked at
each other and you know it was amazing
it was really awesome so to be able to
have a twist ending all these years
later for Shyamalan career it had that
much of an impact on me and a lot of
other people that's impressive but still
I must reiterate I like the movie
already
I really appreciated all of the
performances I thought it was a very fun
psychological thriller I loved the dance
scene with James McAvoy just freaking
out that is such an incredible sequence
and again according to Shaw Milan at the
AFI Fest premiere he's actually acting
out a story of someone dying and then
coming back to life as a zombie
through his dance it's so unique there's
a lot of really cool Easter eggs in the
movie there's a shot of his computer
screen and one of the emails or one of
the contact names is mr. Pritchard if
you're a fan of signs like I am you may
remember Lionel Prichard and the
Wolfington brothers but one of my
favorite things in this movie is the arc
of Anya Taylor Joy's character because
in the beginning you feel like why is
she so at ease why does she know all of
these things why is she telling the girl
to wet her pants why does she know all
these things perfectly and why does she
feel so calm as the movie progresses and
you peel back the layers of her
backstory you realized that as a youth
she has dealt with considerable physical
abuse and possibly as she's even grown
up into adulthood because at the end of
the film the cop is like hey your
uncle's here to pick you up and the look
on her face is like I don't even know
what's happier back with that guy or
going to my uncle but you kind of get
the sense just through the lingering
shot of her face that she's about to be
like you know what fuck that guy I'm not
going back there who knows we'll see if
that arch gets explored more even if it
doesn't I like the way it's left I think
it's really beautiful and haunting
at the same time but it also helps you
understand why she was so rock-solid
throughout those scenarios because she's
dealt with a lot of shit like that
before and that's really smart
storytelling and really brave
storytelling in fact everything about
the storytelling in this movie is brave
because Shyamalan is specifically
trusting the audience to not get bored
and to not ask too many questions and
get angry and leave because the answers
are coming he's not just like hey here's
the characters this is what they are as
the film progresses you learn about them
and it's brilliant storytelling see I'm
a big fan of musical scores and the
unbreakable score by James Newton Howard
is one of my favorites so when James
McAvoy was looking at his wounds in the
mirror and it was like
Oh
like are you fucking kidding me right
now no fucking way and I just look I
actually under my breath I went Kali and
Martellus would sit next to me and he
was like what nothing unbelievable
unbelievable guys what did you think of
split those are my spoiler thoughts on
this movie it's my favorite Shyamalan
films and signs I think it's fantastic I
really can't wait to see if he does more
with this world I feel like one of the
biggest reasons he hasn't announced a
next project is because it's possible
that it could be unbreakable so he
probably doesn't want to like ruin that
for people who don't know and haven't
seen split yet I hope you guys do check
this film out in theaters if you haven't
already guys thank you so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck my
next
[Applause]
[Music]